Одна з головних особливостей роботи пожежників у Німеччині порівняно з Україною
в тому, що у ФРН переважна більшість вогнеборців - це добровольці.
Для них гасіння пожеж -
справа волонтерська і безоплатна.
У Німеччині за пожежну безпеку відповідає адміністрація конкретної громади чи міста.
Професійні пожежні частини є лише у містах
від 100 тисяч населення.
Якщо менше, то рятуватимуть людей і майно пожежники-волонтери.
Їх у ФРН вже понад мільйон, тоді як професійних вогнеборців - 35-40 тисяч.
При цьому оснащення і техніка у добровольців нічим не відрізняється від професіоналів.
У пожежних частинах стоять такі самі пожежні машини, шланги та екіпірування.
Усе це для добровільних пожежних бригад закуповують громади.
Постійно у будівлі знаходиться лише диспетчер -
кімната для чергових пожежників
не передбачена.
На виклик диспетчера пожежники-добровольці прибувають за лічені хвилини.
Вони мають пейджери, на які отримують
сигнал про пожежу.
Нині дедалі більше громад переходять на спеціальнідодатки для смартфонів,
через які і повідомляють про виклик.
Можна навіть відстежувати в онлайн режимі, де знаходяться
закріплені за відділенням пожежники-волонтери.
Їхні роботодавці знають про такудодаткову волонтерську зайнятість,
тому з розумінням ставляться до цього.
Зарплату за роботу пожежника вони не отримують.
Робота пожежного вважається почесною справою,
і німців з дитинства знайомлять з цією професією,
а потім через молодіжні організації готують кадровий резерв.
Нестачі добровольців у Німеччині немає.
Крім того, до лав добровільних вогнеборців приходить дедалі більше жінок:
нині вже кожна десята серед пожежників-волонтерів - жінка.
Підготовка добровільних вогнеборців
не відрізняється від професіоналів.
Вони проходять той самий суворий медогляд, а також різноманітні курси і тренінги,
регулярно підтримуючи в тонусі рівень кваліфікації.
Щоб стати професійним пожежником у Німеччині,
претенденту має бути не більше 32 років на момент подання заявки,
треба мати водійські права, пройти медогляд
і тестування на відповідність цій професії.
Потім закінчити спеціалізовані дворічні курси.
Зарплата до вирахування податків варіюється від двох до трьох тисяч євро
залежно від досвіду, звання та регіону країни.
Працюють професійні пожежники позмінно
з різними варіантами чергування.
24, 16, 12 і 8 годин.
Залежно від федеральної землі, робочий тиждень,
як правило, триває 56 годин.
А у добровольців цілодобових змін не буває -
зазвичай вони мають гнучкий графік чергувань.
Головні завдання німецьких вогнеборців -
гасіння пожеж, технічна допомога при нещасних випадках та аваріях,
порятунок людей і тварин, захист навколишнього середовища та майна
і надання першої допомоги.
При цьому власне на гасіння пожеж у ФРН припадає
лише до 10 відсотків від усієї оперативної роботи вогнеборців.
Через те, що кількість пожеж у Німеччині останніми десятиліттями
суттєво зменшилася, пожежні служби дедалі більше виконують місію рятувальників.
Левова частка - це надання медичної і технічної допомоги громадянам.
А ще - вже ходять легенди про те, як німецькі пожежники активно рятують тварин.
У мережі є чимало прикладів щасливого порятунку кошенят,
єнотів,
косуль і навіть курок на автобані
та свиней,  що розбіглися по дорозі після того
як перекинулася вантажівка.